joined Now by The Shadow culture
secretary Lucy Powell hi Miss Paul it's
great to see you thanks for joining us
on the program this morning
um
we were hearing quite a lot about a
nationalized Energy company what does
that look like
it's not a nationalized Energy company
but a nationally owned a new Energy
company gee the energy
you'll know okay that that many
countries around the world like France
who have EDF energy the Swedish the
Dutch the Chinese have companies that
are owned by the government that invest
in and for the long term to produce uh
clean and new energy for their countries
but more importantly they actually do
that in other countries as well so many
of our assets in this country nuclear
onshore offshore wind and in fact much
of the oil and gas that comes out of the
North Sea is actually owned by Foreign
state owned companies and sometimes this
has been an inhibitor for us in our
country because we can't get investment
in quickly enough but it often means
that we take all the risk with
investment into these nuclean energies
but we don't get any of of the rewards
so we think this is a a really good
policy not just in terms of our national
security and resilience but ensuring
that bills will stay low in the in the
long term as British public uh can can
reap the rewards from these sort of
long-term Investments which we are
making anyway in the new energies of the
future okay so we set up this new
company
um British national British Great
British energy alongside the other
companies
um how does that work and how much is it
going to cost
well we've we've also set out plans for
a sovereign investment Fund in in the
clean uh new technologies of the future
as well so they would draw on some of
those in investment costs but these are
long-term Investments that the company
would uh make make the money back over
over the long term if you like but it
would be the British taxpayers that
would reap the benefits of that not just
put the investment in at the beginning
which is often what we do so one of the
challenges we've had for example in
nuclear energy over recent years is that
we were unable over a long period of
time to to find the right uh investment
partner to to get these new nuclear
plants off the ground EDF energy was was
is one that we we have been working with
so instead of all those delays that come
with that and the British government
having to to underpin that in their
financial
packages it would actually be a
british-owned company that would do that
uh in so making it happen in the first
place also ensuring that we can reap the
benefits from that
how much will it cost to set up
well this is a very popular idea so it's
fully it's fully funded we'd already set
aside through our climate investment
pledge up to 28 billion pounds a year to
invest in the new energies of the future
this is just about the the vehicle by
which we can now actually ensure as I
say that the the British people and
future Bill payers uh get some of the
the reward from these Investments and
those Investments aren't just in other
companies whether it be other
state-owned companies or private
companies because they're the only
options that we have at the moment to
invest in the energy of the future
onshore offshore wind solar tidal
nuclear all of these things are
absolutely critical to our our long-term
energy security needs but also how we're
going to keep bills lower uh in in the
long run so it's a it's a model to
achieve that it's a vehicle to achieve
that we the money is already there it's
just it would have gone to other
companies out outside of our control
okay um will Rupert permanently be
suspended from the labor party for her
comments about the chancellor
well rupa's comments were racist in my
view they were wrong they were
incredibly stupid she's apologized she's
lost the Whip and she's been suspended
from from the whip what usually happens
and it's a matter for the chief whip uh
not for me but what usually happens is
an investigation will follow there will
be be inquiry she will be spoken to I
don't know how long all of those things
will take and what that will mean for
her her future but but losing the whip
so therefore no longer being recognized
as a labor MP is an incredibly serious
sanction and one which uh the chief Whip
and kissed armor as as leader are
unafraid to take when someone does
something as wrong as this no I
understand but I just wondered what what
your view was you say that it was a
racist comment I mean should a racist be
allowed back into the party
well it was a as I say it was a wrong
and racist and and you know entirely
misjudged uh comment and she's already
paying a a heavy price for that and what
happens to her in the future is not my
decision it's one that will get looked
at uh properly by by the chief whip in
consultation with other people and that
is something that that they should deal
with I don't think it probably helps for
me to comment on that further I don't
know I mean you are representing the
labor party here this morning Ms Paul
and you know by all accounts um people
suggesting that you will be in power
before too long it's a reasonable
question should somebody who makes
racist comments be welcome by the labor
party
I think someone who makes comments like
these should face very serious sanction
rupa's already faced uh serious sanction
that will continue
um I don't know how that will be
resolved if it would be resolved or
whether she would be allowed back in the
party but I think what your viewers
should know is that we take these
matters incredibly seriously we act
swiftly uh you know without making this
a sort of you know party political point
I think that does stand in stark
contrast to what we've seen with Boris
Johnson and the conservatives recently
where they don't stand up and take
action against misdemeanors of their own
MPS who have the whip return very
quickly or don't have it withdrawn in
the first place when they're found
guilty of serious sexual harassment for
example so we act swiftly there was no
question that we wanted to send a very
clear signal not just to
um the black community that would have
been profoundly offended by these
comments but I think very many of your
viewers that these comments were wrong
completely unacceptable and the action
is taken I was up there in Liverpool I'm
sorry I missed you um yesterday
um chatted too I know I thought I'd see
you this morning
sorry about that yeah a couple of young
labor members saying that they felt that
if you do get into power in a couple of
years time that Jeremy corbyn should be
part of a labor cabinet what do you
think
well Jeremy is also somebody who doesn't
currently have the labor whip this was
sort of part of some of the discussion
that was had here here at conference but
you know that again is a matter for the
for the chief Whip and uh care as the
leader of the labor party Jeremy knows
what he needs to do he needs to
apologize for uh comments and actions
that he has taken that were very
offensive to to the Jewish community and
accept some of his responsibility in the
findings of the EHR C report he knows
what he needs to do and if he does that
I'm sure he will have uh the whip
reinstated but look Kaylee okay what
we've been doing here this week is
showing ourselves and showing the
country that we are ready we are ready
now uh to govern we think there's a real
possibility a possibility that wasn't
there of Labor winning uh the next
election but there's a real
responsibility on labor now you know the
country is facing a huge economy Atomic
crisis the cost of living crisis people
want an alternative they want someone
else to vote for at the next election
and that puts a huge responsibility on
our shoulders and we've got a big job of
work to do to make sure that we are
ready we've got the good Big Ideas that
people want to see us producing we've
got the policies we've got the team of
people and that we're United and
together and disciplined in our approach
about governing this country and
bringing about the change that we need
to see and I think overwhelming
atmosphere and view of this conference
has been United behind that task ahead
okay a lot of my viewers um listening to
this morning are obviously absolutely
terrified of what was going to happen
with the cost of living crisis both with
their energy bills I know they're capped
but nevertheless a lot of people will
find two and a half thousand pounds an
awful lot of money we're seeing that
goods are going up by 10 at least food
in in the shops and now they have to
deal with potentially a much higher
mortgage rates I'm seeing that labor is
saying that there'll be a free breakfast
club for a new child care system labor
says it'll be paid for by reinstating
the 45 B tax rate when I was speaking to
West streeting yesterday he was talking
about this 45p tax rate being put back
and that would be used for the NHS how
far is 2 billion pounds going to go
well it will go to both of those things
because they're both fully costed within
that 2 billion pound envelope both more
training more doctors and nurses which
is absolutely critical the work the
workforce issues in the NHS are a big
part of the problem as to why we've got
such a backlog and delays uh in our much
beloved NHS and providing breakfast
clubs for children again it's not a huge
amount of money that it takes but it's
so important to families who are
struggling with child care costs but are
also struggling to be able to feed their
children properly so this will help
those families particularly to access
breakfast every morning that helps
children engage engage in their
education as well as helps parents with
those problems with with child care but
you're absolutely right okay every I
don't think there's a family in this
country right now that is not really
desperately worried about how they are
going to make ends meet over this winter
any prices even though they are capped
they are still much higher than they
were last year food prices going up
petrol is still incredibly expensive and
now because of the economic decisions
that this government has taken we're
seeing interest rates coming under huge
pressure and that's going to mean big
increases potentially for mortgage
holders something that will will worry
many people as well so you know that's
why we've been setting out an
alternative economic plan to this sort
of trickle-down Economics where you give
a tax break to a few people at the top
and hope it trickles down to everybody
else it won't it doesn't we've tried
that experiment for 30 years and it
didn't work we need to grow the economy
from the bottom up so that everybody
shares in that almost out of time just
want to ask you about the fact that you
said this is the two things I brought up
are fully costed we also heard from the
boss in his speech yesterday afternoon
he says get the country out of this
endless cycle of crisis with a recovery
plan so far I mean I've been looking on
the website there's just a couple of
paragraphs there where else I find this
fully costed recovery plan
we well what care set out yesterday was
a green Prosperity plan there are a
range of policies within that we've
discussed some of them uh this morning
there's there's other aspects to that I
don't know where on the website it is
but I've got details of it so I could
share them with you after this interview
if you need uh to do that but it's an
ambitious plan about how we can seize
the opportunity of this transition to
Net Zero and a new technological and
Digital Society how we can seize that
opportunity to make sure that we've got
good jobs in all parts of the country
every other country is also engaging in
This Global race for the latest
Technologies for the latest industrial
outputs in in clean energy and we've got
a choice we're either going to lead that
Global race and get these those jobs and
those Technologies in this country or or
we cannot and and we believe that with
the right investment with the right
Partnerships and with things like GB
energy coming on stream we can really
sees those opportunities and that's a
very different economic model it's a
very different Vision to the kind of
country and society that the
conservatives are now pursuing which is
will stand back it's you know we will
not get involved in trying to seize
these opportunities or just give a tax
break to a few at the top we'll let
Bankers bonuses go up through the roof
and we'll hope and pray that that will
reach places like Liverpool Manchester
Burnley or Blackpool well they didn't
over the last 30 years and and they
won't again and I think people are now
seeing a big choice in this country
about the kind of government they want
to see okay it's good to see you sorry
I'm not there in person again hopefully
I'll see you soon thanks a lot
see you soon okay bye thanks a lot